president biden dividing his party with
his state of the union address by trying
to put another nail in the coffin for
defund the police biden changing course
after democrats repeatedly called to cut
funding for law enforcement
the answer is not to defund the police
is to fund the
fund them police resources and training
resources and training they need to
protect our communities
but surprise surprise the squad not
happy biden's speech
with the speech cory bush tweeting this
you didn't mention saving black lives
once in this speech all our country has
done is given more funding to police the
result 2021 set a record for fatal
police shootings defund the police
invest in our communities and aoc
blasting biden for leaving out key
issues from the state of the union
i think there are some themes that
left a little bit to be desired for key
constituencies in the democratic base
but the president's goal was very clear
he was laser focused on
really projecting a theme of unity and i
think he's he stuck to that greg one
thing on the state of the union that
really bothered me when he talked about
defund the police is one it could have
been done two years ago but also but he
talked about the officers that were
killed here in new york by that assassin
at that domestic violence call officers
rivera and mora and in within the same
sentence he says um so we must come
together to protect our communities
restore trust and hold law enforcement
accountable of course that's not what
happens in that case he says that after
you know i gotta
i'm not gonna let the media
strategy of contrasting the squad with
joe biden to somehow reconstitute the
myth of his moderation right you got to
give credit to the squad because they're
stupid they're wrong they're
unforgivable but at least they're
consistent to their principles this
jackass
did was didn't do a thing when cops were
being killed when when when when
businesses were being burned he hid in
his basement and only when it became
politically expedient when he was
worried about losing an election and now
when an election is coming up all of a
sudden he's backing the blue because he
felt it was better at the time right to
embrace the woke orthodoxy that put blm
above law enforcement that's what he did
so i'm sorry when i see you know cnn's
recently purchased conservatives you
know those principal few supporting oh
isn't this great look at him such a good
thing
you're an idiot because this guy was
nowhere to be found lastly the thing
that gets me back that gets me crazy is
i know a lot of people are pissed off
about these two republicans that heckled
that's nothing compared to this cosplay
that you see the stand up and applause
the sit down no matter how stupid biden
says something people have to applause
this is kabuki applause line theater
right and we are expected as idiot
americans to go oh wow everything coming
out of his mouth is somehow majestic and
moral and meaningful of course not and
by the way both sides do this right but
for some reason it is more disgusting
heckling is bad but heckling is real
what we watched there was fake and for
anybody applauding him supporting law
enforcement you're an idiot
judge on that or sorry well you know i i
got to tell you greg i actually thought
about that and because it is theater
this politics is theater right okay and
the you know the guy as he ran for
president from his basement didn't say a
word when the streets were burning and
when he was president didn't say a word
the democrat national committee when
they had their uh uh
their their uh
convention didn't say a word now his
numbers are in the tank 37 percent oh i
want to fund the police okay that's
nonsense if you believe it you're stupid
but the fact that they stood up and
applauded i really thought to myself you
know janine if i were there would i have
stood up and applauded and you know the
the intellectual part of me says you
have to applaud that because we have to
recognize at least when he says it he
doesn't he doesn't mean it he doesn't
believe it he's a trojan horse we've got
to recognize that this is who we are as
americans we're a law and order society
every everything that came out of his
mouth i thought last night and we there
were some polls that showed that even
the independents were skeptical not just
the republicans but the independents
were skeptical and you know when he
talks about you know funding the police
and all of a sudden he's on the side of
truth and justice i mean it's nonsense
everybody knows it's nonsense he came to
new york and oh he's going to stop the
flow of guns how are you going to stop
the flow of guns if criminals keep
getting out and getting guns it's not
about anything new you got to prosecute
the crimes you got to change the law you
got to convict them and send their butts
to jail all right it's just it's theater
that's all it is he abandoned the
streets and then it's his fault i like
how you agreed disagreed and then agreed
with me it's just no
no
and we haven't had a chance to hear from
jesse harold and i were on last night
but yeah biden doesn't even know how to
capitalize off the kabuki theater he's
giving them a standing ovation
for backing the blue and he just steps
on it with his next sentence just soak
in the moment joe they're giving you a
standing o he did it again when they
were chanting usa
and he steps on it and starts reading
the teleprompter you got to let the usa
chant go bro
that said
he's just trying to sound like he
likes the police he's actually not
trying to fight crime see there's a
difference if he wanted to fight crime
he would have talked about the gangs and
the cartels and the soft da's and the
light sentencing and the bail he didn't
do any of that he just tried to play
defense with the squad that's how you
know he doesn't care about crime
reduction he just makes it out to be
like a political wound that he's trying
to put a bandage on that's why i don't
like the guy because he actually doesn't
want to do the right thing he's just
trying to sound like he's doing the
right thing okay and i want i want to
play the covet is over sound but we
haven't had a chance really to talk
about this we talked about all lots of
other things in the speech but this was
something that we picked up on last
night as well
thanks to the progress we've made in the
past year covet 19 no longer need
control our lives
i know some are talking about living
with covet 19 but tonight i say
that we never will just accept living
with cover 19 we'll continue to combat
the virus
as we do other diseases
this was also theater for weeks they
could have decided to make these well
maybe even months could have decided to
back off on the masks but it just
magically happened harold that just like
the night before they had to wear a mask
and all of a sudden they don't have to
wear masks but they did have to be
socially distanced and also have
assigned seeds but maybe not but then
give each other hugs it was all nonsense
to me on that front but i'm glad we're
back to normal
yeah i mean i i'm a believer that maybe
i'm stupid for believing some of the
things that he shared or not and that
wasn't directed at you but
no but no no no but what i mean is i i i
like it when people change their mind
about something i like it and i don't
think that biden has really changed his
mind biden remember he authored the 1994
crime build the bill that got hillary
all jammed up and got him all jammed up
and he jamming up his ass so he's he's
been there a lot doesn't speak to the
political shifting that he would he was
politically there then he changes
whenever it's political
he he didn't come out perhaps as
emphatically as he as you may have
wanted others may have won in denouncing
some things last last summer but he's
never been one to say defund the police
was he it sometimes he kowtow to some of
these
[Laughter]
i thought the speech i thought he missed
some moments the usa line i didn't i
could not believe he didn't let that
chance and there was a democrats
chanting it i mean
the camera never got a chance to see
democrats doing that but hey
speech is over now
would you like to comment on the theater
of the masks um no but i love the line
he said
i have a better idea to fight inflation
lower your costs
not your wages does he is it aware that
lowering your costs means firing people
he you know
but this is a straw man he's setting up
he thinks that republicans want
basically just to cut your wages and
that's how they're going to get out of
inflation yeah he's going to lower your
cost by spending another trillion
dollars and capitalism capitalism
without competition
is exploitation he says that like he's
living in a freshman dorm he keeps
saying it but the fact is
who hates competition it's the left
they're the ones that are removing
competition from this from education so
education without competition
competition is exploitation
spoken like a sophomore in college yes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else